hit man's first episodic season is  coming to a head and you'll get your  hands on the finale very soon I'm Tony  and this is your climactic gamespot news  update the Hitman finale is called situs  inversus and it takes place in Hokkaido  Japan the map itself is a private  hospital and resort which publisher  Square Enix calls a quote fusion of  japanese beauty and cutting-edge  technology agent 47 will explore a Zen  garden sushi restaurant hot spring and  more as he hunts down his two targets  and although this is the finale lead  writer michael vote says the story is  just getting started so you can probably  expect a twist or two hitman season once  final map goes live on ps4 xbox one and  pc on October thirty-first the complete  first season is also getting a physical  release on the same platforms in July  with a few extras included developer IO  Interactive's goal is to have three  seasons of the game but to keep up with  all the Hitman news you're already in  the right place